the very thought of Thanksgiving drums
up foods worth salivating over like
stuffing mashed potatoes and of course
the tofurkey
but this Thanksgiving veggie substitute
wasn't just whipped up overnight it
actually took years of trial and error
so we called the guy who invented it I
am Seth Tibbett and I am the inventor of
tofurkey Seth Tibbett was living in
Oregon he was a teacher and a
self-professed hippy who lived somewhere
shall we say unusual I built my own
three-story tree house out of scavenged
wood he was also a serious vegetarian so
serious that he started his very own
tempeh making company and I made soy
tempeh 5 grain tempeh and a sausage
tempeh called Temper Oni and I just made
tempeh for the first 15 years but there
was a problem which was finding
something to eat at my own Thanksgiving
you see at the time there were no main
dishes for vegetarians available so Seth
set out to solve the problem and it
wasn't so easy
first he created a stuffed pumpkin the
stuffed pumpkin was the famous one that
we still talk about the whole thing and
the pumpkin was that it collapsed in the
oven and it seemed more like a side dish
than a main dish then there was the
gluten roast which was really an all-day
thing took like eight hours literally it
was just too tough to cut with any kind
of implement that we had other than a
chainsaw which we did not bring to the
table
eventually seth teamed up with his
friend hans he was making these tofu
roasts had a little bit of gravy in
there with them we've had at the
drumettes because we were mimicking the
turkey and marketed it under the name
tofurkey
throughout the years the recipe evolved
we soon realized that this is a vegan
feast and vegan plants don't have legs
so yeah it's been a long journey long
strange tempeh trip as a hippie would
say and now around here we call Turkey a
Tofurky substitute
[Music]